[Music]
rising out of the forests and what was
once a wasteland is a masterpiece
that has taken decades to build
and the guy behind it says he's not
finished yet
what y'all something don't wallow judges
Akito wait I needed general go some more
Anderson in Chiang Mai Tawhiti [ __ ]
[Music]
hey Lunas building this valley is a
tribute to the ancient civilization that
once lived here
it covers nearly 50 acres and most of it
has been built by hand do you EPB a
family and I know how you condo in here
send me the window hold on
this is a hotel it was thought that
these masks had the power to help people
overcome hardships and ward off diseases
while pay lune besides the design of
every structure at these locals who
really know the stonework sweet harmony
they told us little details for the
release of him they ever needed a time
donkey you know coming together you can
go to Sony or more generally I'll go
Donny took a little harmony too late no
wonder this place wasn't built only with
a tribute in mind an artist himself
Palin wanted others to be inspired by
his work and form a community attended
to them a million angry you you [ __ ]
hiya resin a calling card okay Polly
wants a so yoga say we do momen
literally do get hatha yoga India so
they went and away by the Susan go
please identify me tell him
[Music]